it is a rare opportunity for fans of
Disney memorabilia I'll say for the past
63 years
Disneyland in Anaheim California has
drawn millions of visitors from all over
the world becoming known as the happiest
place on earth spent many a birthday
there
well now fans have a chance to take
historic pieces of Disney home to their
place to their place on earth Jamie
yuccas reports with the dream assignment
from Los Angeles this former sporting
goods store is 40 miles and more than an
hour's drive away from Disneyland but
once you get inside mr. Toad's Wild Ride
this is from Peter Pan's flight it's
easy to imagine you're right in the
middle of the happiest place on earth
everybody has their own hometown but
everyone's collective hometown is
Disneyland Richard crafts is a Los
Angeles talent agent who has spent the
past 25 years collecting more than a
thousand Disneyland artifacts because
I'm deranged and obsessive one poster
became every poster then it became ride
vehicles and there was no stopping
like many grown-up kids crafts has
indelible childhood memories of his
family's visits to Disneyland but for
the crafts family those trips were much
more than a simple vacation that older
brother with Crohn's disease so we had
to wait for a day that he was feeling
well so a trip to Disneyland was like
the best day of the year it was
Disneyland and my brother being healthy
25 years ago crafts brother David passed
away and Richard consoled himself with
an impromptu trip to Disneyland office
and all these memories of my childhood
with my brother came rushing back and
shortly after that there was an auction
I heard about of pieces of Disneyland
that auction started it all these loud
guys over here are it's a small world
figures and now crafts has amassed a
collection including everything from
larger-than-life sea serpents to the
creepy stretch paintings from the
Haunted man
but soaring above it all is crafts pride
and joy everybody on planet Earth has
been in this Dumbo am I correct an
800-pound Dumbo which for many years
hung in crafts living room his ears are
eight feet long and would not get
through our front door so we did the
logical thing we bought a different
house and moved to one with French doors
for the next two weeks it's all on
display in this free exhibit and then it
all goes up for auction I gotta send it
back out into the world I keep hearing
the voice of the great poet Elsa saying
let it go let it go and I'm just
following directions these things don't
get sold off Mike van Eaton is staging
the exhibit and auction he predicts this
animatronic bird from the Enchanted Tiki
Room could go for up to $100,000 and
Dumbo could fetch up to twice that
amount these items really trigger a lot
of childhood memories for people there's
a lot of love here and we've had people
who actually have started crying when
they see a vehicle that reminded of some
experience I had when their child crafts
insisted on staging this free exhibit
before the auction so he could share his
happiness with as many people as
possible so far in the first week we had
10,000 people come through and we had
10,000 legitimately happy people and as
for the collection itself I hope it all
gets happy homes if they weren't happy
already artifacts like these will likely
do the trick for CBS this morning
Saturday Jamie yuccas Los Angeles
dibs on Dumbo Dumbo I went down Bo dibs
you know I lost a bear there in 1985 but
it's easy let me know